senate democrats are making plans to
pass president biden's sweeping 1.9
trillion coveted relief package with or
without republican support
a group of 10 gop senators is proposing
a much smaller measure
and urging the president to follow
through on his promise to work with
republicans
wishing is at the white house with more
on this part of the story wisha good
morning to you
good morning to you gail late last night
those republican senators announced they
will be meeting with president biden
today here at the white house
they accepted his invitation after
sending him a letter
outlining their proposal but mr biden
has already indicated he is not
interested in signing
a watered-down version of his own
with republicans offering less than a
third of what he proposed for his
coveted relief bill the president is
signaling the time for bipartisanship
is running out i support passing cobra
relief
with support from republicans if we can
get it but the cover relief has to pass
there's no if ands or buts late last
night the white house said president
biden is prepared to begin
action on his rescue plan after speaking
with democratic leaders
he will meet with gop senators today but
the administration made clear
the need for action is urgent and the
scale of what must be done
is large that large action has a 1.9
trillion dollar price tag
and republicans are urging the president
to consider
a cheaper 600 billion dollar package
among the key differences stimulus
checks would provide 1 000
instead of 1400 and recipients would be
capped at lower income brackets
louisiana senator bill cassidy part of a
bipartisan group working on covid relief
slammed the white house for not asking
for input while crafting the bill
if you want unity if you want
bipartisanship you ought to start with a
group that's shown it's willing to work
together
for a common solution they did not but
president biden can get his plan through
without
any republican support using a process
called reconciliation
which would only require a simple
majority in the senate
vermont senator bernie sanders is
confident democrats would stick together
it's hard for me to imagine any democrat
no matter what state he or she may come
from
who doesn't understand the need to go
forward
right now in an aggressive way to
protect the working families
the senators will soon have to split
their time negotiating coveted relief
and
holding a trial for former president
trump which is set to begin on tuesday
yesterday mr trump announced a brand new
legal team
just in the nick of time their first
response to the charge to congress
is due tomorrow tony let's talk about
that brand new legal team what more do
we know about it
well the defense team for this historic
impeachment trial will be led by david
shone who previously represented
long-time trump associate
roger stone and bruce castor a former
district attorney
in pennsylvania over the weekend mr
trump's first defense team
fell apart amid reports that he wanted
them to play up those
baseless claims of election fraud where
the lawyers wanted to focus on whether
the impeachment was constitutional
trump advisor jason miller said they
left as part of a mutual
decision tony call it a conscious
uncoupling wija thank you very much
the middle of